[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNIE WILKES: I am your
number one fan, I sure am.
And trust me, there
ain't no number two.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN SEALES: Whoo!
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
So it would probably
be easiest here
if you-- let's start with
you, Michael, on the end.
Just go down the line here
and introduce yourselves.
MARK KAUFMAN: Mark Kaufman.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, Mark.
Sorry.
MARK KAUFMAN: No-- producer.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: Michael
Friedman, composer.
LEON ADDISON BROWN: Leon
Addison Brown, actor.
LAURIE METCALF: Laurie
Metcalf, act-- or.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL FREARS: Are you sure?
LAURIE METCALF: Yes, I am sure.
WILL FREARS: Will
Frears, director.
ALAN SEALES: Laurie, you were
covering your ears during that.
Is that--
LAURIE METCALF: I had to be
tapped to walk up on the stage
because I was bent over like
that with my ears covered.
Because I can't
watch any of that.
Because it's very
distressing to me.
ALAN SEALES: Does it
scare you to watch it
as much as it scares
the rest of us?
LAURIE METCALF:
No, it's not scary.
I can't watch myself--
ALAN SEALES: Oh, right.
LAURIE METCALF:
--because in my head,
it looks completely different
than what that just is.
So I can't see it.
ALAN SEALES: Interesting.
So you've had a very
versatile career.
I mean, you've been
in many movies, lots
of television, "Roseanne,"
of course, where
you won three Emmy awards.
Numerous theater
productions, where
you got two Tony nominations.
And you're even the voice of
Andy's mom in the "Toy Story"
movies, which I was
very happy to discover.
Is there any particular genre
that you like more than others?
LAURIE METCALF: Oh,
yeah, theater, by far.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
LAURIE METCALF: Yeah.
Maybe it's because I
came up in theater,
with Steppenwolf
Theatre in Chicago,
and we're in our 40th
season, I think, now.
And so I started
there, and that's
where I learned-- I like the
instant gratification of being
in front of a live audience.
And I like the rehearsal
process very much.
I like the three, four weeks
spent in a rehearsal room
really hammering out things.
And I like the run of the show.
It's all really
different skill sets,
but I much prefer theater.
ALAN SEALES: Wow, so you've been
through the rehearsal process.
So with movies, I don't imagine
you rehearse the whole thing
all at once.
LAURIE METCALF: No.
ALAN SEALES: So you rehearse.
You go in, and you're like,
oh, here are my lines.
You've usually got them
in your back pocket.
LAURIE METCALF: Exactly.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
And you rehearse it.
LAURIE METCALF: You do it out
of order, out of sequence.
You're shooting the very last
scene of the movie first.
ALAN SEALES: So is that a
challenge for a show like
"Misery," where you're on stage
pretty much 90% of the time,
I would say?
LAURIE METCALF: Yes, we get
on the "Misery-go-round,"
and we don't get off
for an hour and a half.
ALAN SEALES: A literal go-round.
Yeah, I want to
come back to that.
The set is phenomenal.
But approaching the character of
Annie Wilkes, your crazy number
one fan obsession person,
I mean, she's nuts.
Do you have any personal
sympathy for her?
LAURIE METCALF: Yeah, I do.
I have a lot of sympathy.
That's what attracted
me to the part.
Because I was looking for-- we
were just talking about it--
the heart of the character,
because there has to be.
It can't just be
labeled a "monster."
And so there are very
few tiny, tiny hints
in the script of maybe the
way that she was brought up,
maybe her relationship
to her mother,
her relationship to her
miserable stepfather,
as she just fleetingly mentions.
The fact that she deals
with Bruce's character
in a certain way, everything
is very black and white.
There's a scene
where she makes him--
it's kind of like washing
his mouth out with soap
and drink this water.
But to me, it just always was
about how she was brought up.
And so that she wasn't born
this person that is abusive.
And there's a back history
that's hinted at that.
When you see it,
hopefully, you forgive
her a lot of her craziness.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
it was weird for me
to watch because at
first-- I'm going
to try to talk without
giving away any spoilers.
Because you guys have
to go see the show.
At first, I thought--
LAURIE METCALF:
But don't everybody
know-- doesn't most-- what's the
majority of people that know,
I mean, what happens?
ALAN SEALES: Who's seen
the movie or read the book?
OK, I guess that
is the majority.
LAURIE METCALF: Most.
ALAN SEALES: I had not seen
either-- seen the movie
or read the book-- so I
went in completely fresh.
And--
LAURIE METCALF: That's
got to be disturbing.
ALAN SEALES: Yes,
that's why I was
so excited to talk to you
guys, because I'm still
disturbed for many reasons.
And Leon, we'll get to
your scene in a second.
God, it scared the
shit out of me.
Excuse me, Spencer.
Yeah, so your character
gets so manic.
And at first, I was very
sympathetic with her.
And I was like, oh,
OK, she means well.
She's very, very nice.
And then it's just like,
well, that escalated quickly.
Again, I don't know want
to give away the spoilers
for those who haven't seen it.
But they're like
disfiguration, right?
That's not a spoiler.
You've got to go see it.
So how did you
approach this from sort
of a character leveling,
emotional leveling perspective?
LAURIE METCALF: Yeah,
you do have to plot.
It has to ramp up.
You can't just go full--
ALAN SEALES: Full crazy?
LAURIE METCALF:
Full crazy-- right,
right-- right out of the gate.
There are some entry level
drugs that get to the--
but the mania, I think,
comes from her out
of proportion fandom for
this particular writer.
And so the times where she
is rewarded with something--
hearing that he's got
another book coming out, or--
ALAN SEALES: Forcing
it to happen?
LAURIE METCALF: And so
those are the times where
she spikes up in the mania.
And another time is when
he's been doing some writing.
And he has said that her
favorite character, Misery
Chastain, now comes
from nobility, which she
knew all the time [INAUDIBLE].
And then there's another
spike of rolling around
on the bed like a crazy person.
So those are the
fun mania moments.
And then there are others
that are not so fun for him.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So working with
director Will Frears,
how much of the
character of Annie
did you bring to
the table combined
with what Laurie brought?
WILL FREARS: I mean,
I don't think--
I like to think we
sort of-- I mean,
mostly I listen to Laurie
because she's brilliant,
and I try not to get in her way.
We talk a lot.
I mean, as we were
getting started,
we would spend hours
together talking about it,
talking where we agreed,
where we disagreed,
where we saw things.
And one of the great
pleasures of the whole thing
is that it's been astonishing
to watch Laurie take what
is a sort of iconic figure
in a particular thing
and sort of reinvent it
entirely as she sees her,
and to find this incredible
kind of sympathy.
I think the thing we
agreed on, always,
was that she couldn't
be a monster, though.
We always felt that we had
to look for her humanity
and that everything she did, we
both, right from the beginning,
forgave for, and
tried to understand.
And then from there, really, I
think it's been that I've felt
like, if I'm lucky enough
to have Laurie like that,
don't get into-- I mean, suggest
and nudge but don't-- to just
try and see what she's doing
and help her illuminate that,
but to very much give her her
head and see where she takes
it.
It's thrilling, and every time
I go back and see the show,
I'm like, oh, that's a new--
ALAN SEALES: [CHUCKLES]
WILL FREARS: --oh, she's clever.
That's very smart.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
WILL FREARS: It's really
exciting to come back.
I've become such a fan that
I go back as Annie Wilkes.
ALAN SEALES: Is that unusual
to be a fan of your own show?
WILL FREARS: I'm not
a fan of my show.
I'm a fan of Laurie.
They're very-- I'm a fan
of everyone else in it.
I'm not at all a fan--
I sit there and cringe
for my own work.
And then I think,
oh, they're smart.
Thanks for rescuing me again.
No, part of the
pleasure for this thing
is this is-- because I
haven't had a show on Broadway
before-- to watch a show
run this long, for me,
is a real treat.
And to see Bruce and Laurie
and Leon find new things,
change things, add nuance,
add meaning, add texture,
so that every time I go back,
it's things they've found.
It's not at all things that
I have been like, oh, god,
that was such a good idea by me.
It's watching them investigate
another part of the play,
find a new beat,
find a different way
of doing something.
It's just a kind
of-- it's a treat.
Because, as Laurie said at the
beginning, it sort of lives.
It's a living
organism, and so you
get to go back and visit it.
But it's not at all as
a fan-- not a fan of me
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
which is, personally,
why I enjoy doing
theater over film.
Because even though up to
rehearsals, the script changes,
and whatnot, you lock it in.
But even though it's locked, you
can say the exact same things
every night and have them mean
completely different things.
They have different subtexts.
So Will, you've been
involved with movies,
both in front of the camera
and behind the camera.
WILL FREARS: Only once in
front, and I was playing myself.
So it wasn't huge.
It was interesting that
somebody called me and said,
will you come play
a theater director?
And I was like, yeah.
OK.
ALAN SEALES: All right, easy.
And action.
So you were an actor
and writer and whatnot,
but you've been doing a
lot of directing recently.
How did you get
involved with "Misery"?
WILL FREARS: I got a
call from my agent.
It's a sort of really-- it's
the most traditional story.
I got a call from
my agent, saying,
what are you doing next week?
And I said, well, I'm quite busy
next week, because on Sunday,
my wife is going into hospital
and we're-- she's going to have
a baby.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, congrats.
WILL FREARS: Thank you.
And he said, OK, but
later in the week.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: I
[INAUDIBLE] and sleep.
WILL FREARS: Uh-huh.
And I said, well, could
we do it next week?
And he said that
there had been a call,
and could I go and
meet about "Misery."
And so I sat in the
hospital room at NYU
with my two-day-old
daughter, and I'm just
reading this book-- trying
to reconcile becoming
a father with this horror.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Please don't
make it turn out like this.
WILL FREARS: And I took
meetings with everyone.
And I took meetings with Mark.
Mark and I had breakfast at
the Brooklyn Diner, I think,
was where we first sat down.
MARK KAUFMAN: That was
our first meal, yeah.
WILL FREARS: And I started
working with Bill Goldman,
And that was how it started,
and we sort of clicked.
And the original draft of the
script was all in projections.
It was all done with
like, she does a thing,
and then an image would
flash on the screen.
And I said to Bill,
I was like, look,
you don't have to give
me this job at all.
But if you don't do these
things for real on stage,
the audience is
going to hate you.
There's quite some significant
acts of violence in the play,
and they were all
done back there.
And I was like, look, if
you don't actually do the--
ALAN SEALES: Like a
silhouette, or something?
WILL FREARS: No, like a picture.
Like in still-- like a film.
And I was, like, you have to
do the thing-- for those of you
who know what the thing
is, you have to do that,
or they'll hate you for it.
And he went, can
you really do that?
And I said, yeah.
And he said, fuck.
ALAN SEALES: Sorry, Spencer.
WILL FREARS: Sorry--
or not sorry.
And that was how
we started working.
And so the first
thing we did was we
took out all these projections
and went on from there.
And that was five years ago.
ALAN SEALES: Five years?
Wow.
OK.
WILL FREARS: Two children.
ALAN SEALES: So Mark,
I guess five years ago,
you started this.
Warner Brothers, big studio--
big studio execs sitting here,
right?
Yes, that's what I
tell myself, and that's
what you should tell yourself.
And so you got involved.
We were talking a little
bit at lunch about this.
But I want to go into
a little bit more.
This is the first
show on Broadway
I've seen where I've realized
that a big movie studioesque
kind of organization
owned the rights
and then put it on stage.
So how did Warner
Brothers, in general,
even get to own the
rights in the first place?
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: Well, I'll
go with the quick answers.
First of all, we're sort of
following in the footsteps
of other studios.
Disney, obviously,
started paving the way
with their shows.
And Universal's
involved in "Wicked."
But I actually didn't
put it into development.
I came after it had already
been in development.
So I was the next
regime who decides,
do things move forward or
do things sort of stop?
And one of the things--
my very first meeting
when I started the
studio was "Misery"
is in development with Bill
Goldman, who I had actually
hired for another project,
as a movie studio executive,
to write.
So we had a shorthand.
And I met Will, as he said,
at the Brooklyn Diner.
And there was something
about "Misery"
that I just really loved.
And I always felt-- part
of what I was brought on
to do when I was
hired at the studio
was to go through the catalog
and see which movie or TV
projects or cartoons felt
like they belonged on stage.
And "Misery" felt like
such a natural to me.
And I had also this
very interesting story
with Bill Goldman.
I was in graduate
school, and Bill Goldman
came to speak to
us about "Misery."
So I had this weird
connection from almost--
it had to be 20-something
years earlier.
And I also had this weird
connection to-- when I grew up,
there was a play
called "Deathtrap"
that I was obsessed with.
And I saw it three, four times.
And I always wanted to
do that on Broadway.
And they don't do
those shows anymore.
So this sort of ticked three
or four different boxes.
I wanted to work with Bill.
I was really taken by Will.
I loved the property.
I'd seen the movie
and read the book.
And it just felt like a natural
to push forward, and we did.
ALAN SEALES: You
said, Bill Goldman.
William Goldman--
MARK KAUFMAN: Sorry.
ALAN SEALES: --wrote
the original screenplay
for the movie with Kathy Bates.
So was it a kind of a
no-brainer to bring him back?
Because he wrote the
screenplay, right?
Or wrote the book for this.
MARK KAUFMAN: He actually
comes from theater
before he was in movies.
Years ago, he
wrote, oh, my god, I
think it was a Kander and
Ebb musical with his brother
James, the happy time
in the late '50s.
And he wrote a bunch
of books about theater.
"Season" is an incredible book.
If anybody hasn't read
it, it's unbelievable.
So he was already hired.
So it was just a matter of
do we continue with him?
And I was in awe of him
in our first meeting,
when he was telling
me all the things.
And I have to say,
Will had already
handled the projection stuff.
So I didn't-- those were so
taken care of by the time I
came on.
So now, I got the
exciting stuff.
And Bill, when I
remember-- William,
sorry-- when we had our first
lunch, he was telling me this.
And I was like a kid
in a candy store.
I was like, oh, my
god, this is great.
And so it just got me excited.
And it was very easy to push it.
ALAN SEALES: So were there any
budgetary or licensing hurdles
to overcome?
Or was it just like,
oh, cool, put it on.
Let's do it?
MARK KAUFMAN: Well, we shared
the rights with Castle Rock.
It was actually their idea.
Liz Glotzer and
Martin Shafer came
to Warner Brothers, the
previous regime in theater
to do the play.
So they put it into development.
And so we shared the
rights with them,
so it was an obvious
thing going forward.
But we also did an out-of-town.
After we worked on it a little
bit, we went to Bucks County
in Pennsylvania and did an
out-of-town tryout there.
And the response was terrific.
And we also knew-- it set
us on a path of, oh, these
are the things we need
to do going forward.
And I think we made
great progress.
And you said, when Laurie
and Bruce got into the room
with Will, I mean, they
sat there and talked
for a long time.
I was not part of
those conversations,
because they really wanted
to just become that group.
And what came out of it
was incredible and really
just sort of pushed it further
down the path to Broadway.
ALAN SEALES: So.
I mean, WBTV has
done a lot of stuff.
And even right now on
Broadway, "The Curious Incident
of the Dog in the
Night-Time" is you guys.
"Bridges of Madison
County," "Elf," the "Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory"
musical that's in London right
now, that you guys own.
So compared to those--
you keep going on
about "Misery," about
it was just like, yeah,
it's a no-brainer.
We do it, we do it.
But compared to all of
those, are all of them
that easy to greenlight?
Or were you--
MARK KAUFMAN: No.
ALAN SEALES: --just coming
in here like, oh, yeah,
Laurie Metcalf, genius, do it?
MARK KAUFMAN: By the way,
that was an easy decision.
Laurie Metcalf, genius, do it.
Yes, that was easy.
No, they're not all that easy.
And some are good ideas,
and some are bad ideas,
and some will get reworked.
One of the things I
was very excited about
was we do a lot of musicals.
We did "Charlie."
We did "Elf."
We were involved with
"Madison County."
The National Theatre came to
us for "Curious Incident."
We jumped on that.
We wanted to do something
else after "Misery."
And we said, all
right, what movie
lends itself to the same--
what is another movie that
could be turned into
a play that feels
like it's very theatrical?
We're not just
doing it because we
want to put something on stage.
But it really feels like it
would take it a step forward
by being on stage.
And our next-- we just
announced last week,
we're going to be doing "Dog Day
Afternoon," with Stephen Adly
Guirgis adapting it.
So it has to be the right idea.
And I think that sounds
like the right idea
for the way it was picked up.
But we'll develop
it and we'll see.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So Michael Friedman,
original music
and original sound design.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: No,
Darron West is the sound.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, sorry.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: He
would be very mad at me
if I said I did the sound.
ALAN SEALES: Oh.
So, I mean, over and
over again, the lighting
and the sound design are used
to indicate the passing of time,
which I think the way that
you did it in the show
was brilliant.
Was that one of the
original slides,
or it's just the stuff
that we shall not
talk about that was slides?
WILL FREARS: Oh,
everything was slides.
I mean, the whole thing was.
It was like there was a bed
and a projection machine.
It was like, this is
a-- then he does this.
Then he does-- and
it would-- you'd
just be like-- I'm so--
like it was just all slides.
It was like something
from the 19th century.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Well, the sound
and the lighting-- yeah,
I think it's
absolutely brilliant.
And I was wondering,
because I knew
that it was going to take
place over multiple days
and going into weeks.
And I was like, OK, first
off, there's one room.
OK, it rotated to
start, but that's it.
But how did you guys come
up with the overall concept
for the underscoring
of the show,
in addition to the lighting?
You guys have things like
mobile gobos that move,
that make it look like cars
are driving by, and whatnot.
It' brilliant.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: Well, David
Weiner, our lighting designer,
is a genius at
that kind of thing.
So it is, as you
say, the thing that's
trickiest to do in theater
is to have time pass,
because our show
is 90 minutes long.
And a novel can
take a lot of time.
So there are a lot of
scenes in the play.
And so, the major thing that
we had to come up with first
was how to tell the story of
now one night passes, now four
nights pass.
It's been snowing a lot.
It's been raining.
The seasons are changing.
So we all worked--
it was actually
one of the hardest things.
I think, also on
the actors, in terms
of exactly how long those
transitions should be,
and where the play
needs to breathe,
needs to get tauter.
So the music and sound
and lighting departments
all spent long and tedious
hours building those.
So I'm glad that you
liked them, because they
were really hard to do.
I've never seen,
actually, a show
that exists quite
in that way in terms
of telling a story about
time between the scenes.
And I hope that it allows
the actors to then get
the right lift-off
into each scene.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, I
found it extremely unique.
Did you get tech
butt while you were
sitting in the house, yeah?
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: We
got a lot of tech butt.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
They were saying--
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: I never want
to eat the ramen at the place
on 44th Street again.
ALAN SEALES: They were marveling
at our Googler at La Place,
over here, the cafe.
And I said, you've got to
watch out for the Googler 20.
And they said, you've got
to watch out for tech butt.
When you sit in the house all
the time, you get tech butt.
WILL FREARS: Everyone's
very graciously
put a bucket of candy on your
table, and you just look.
ALAN SEALES: So how
is the composing
of music for a play different
from the composition
for a musical?
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN:
Well, I'll admit
that when I was telling people
I was working on "Misery,"
there would be this weird
look of horror in their faces.
And then I'd say, oh,
it's not a musical.
And they'd go, oh,
that's a good idea.
[LAUGHTER]
So it was like, oh, you think
I'd write a really bad musical.
But the trick of-- I
mean, horror movies
rely on music hugely.
And the tricky
part of "Misery" is
the tone is really interesting.
Because it's both scary,
and psychological,
and suspenseful, and at
the same time, very funny.
And the thing that music
can do better than anything
is destroy humor.
So my first job,
in a funny way, was
to not kill what the actors
were doing beautifully,
that as soon as you
add music under it,
the audience is just sitting
there and nothing happens.
So like Will said, getting
out of the actor's way
is part of my job.
But the fun part
was, horror allows
you to do all sorts of
things-- bad taste things
that I would never allow myself.
Anyone who sees the show,
the final cue of the show
is completely tasteless.
But one of the fun things in
the show is that in the script,
Annie's different mood
shifts are indicated by what
Liberace she's listening to.
So we started with the idea
of this Liberace piano.
And I sort of let that start
infecting the other music.
And then I just watched
"Psycho" over and over again.
The score of "Psycho"
is the best horror movie
score of all time.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, yeah, yeah.
Wow.
So Leon Addison Brown,
you play Buster.
I watched the show
last week, like I
said, having not read the
book or watched the movie.
And your-- gosh,
how do I-- I don't
want to give any spoilers away.
Your--
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN:
Climactic moment.
WILL FREARS: Climactic thing.
ALAN SEALES: Your
climactic moment
scared the everloving
shit out of me.
And I was sitting
house-right, so I
didn't see Laurie behind you.
So I was completely-- I
didn't anticipate anything.
And I was like, why is
he just standing there
weirdly like that?
OK.
And then, boom, it
happened-- literally.
Does your character--
I mean, you kind of
come in and out of the
scene the whole time.
Backstage, do you have
your own character arc
that you're dealing
with with all of this?
LEON ADDISON BROWN: I do.
The difficult thing about
it is that I warm up,
and then I have to wait.
So by the time I
get on, I'm feeling
like I need to warm up again.
Then you're on for
that little short time,
and then you wait again.
So that part of it is
difficult, just staying in it.
So I listen to the
whole show every night.
I'm actually sometimes watching
the monitor when I'm not
getting changed, just to
sort of keep myself in it,
so I don't feel like I'm
starting from zero again.
I watch the time pass.
I watch the seasons change.
I just do all that stuff.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Oh, so, talk about
the seasons changing,
I want to talk about
the set for a second.
Because I believe that it's
just brilliantly designed.
And I hope you can
comment on-- hopefully,
you have some input on this.
I want to praise you.
WILL FREARS: I hope so too.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, yeah.
The set, for those who will go
see it-- I'm not giving things
away, because the first thing
that happens is the whole set
turns-- there's four rooms
essentially in this house.
So the whole stage
is a giant turntable,
and you get to see at various
points each of the four rooms,
or three rooms and outside.
And part of the white walls move
to shift around for the actors,
to give you guys more space.
And I think it's
absolutely brilliant.
How did that set come to be?
It's very unique compared to
anything I've seen before.
WILL FREARS: It came
to be, actually,
in a very specific way, which
is that David Korins, who's not
here, and I were having a
sort of early conversation
about what we wanted
it to be like.
And we felt very strongly.
I mean, it all comes back
to the same idea, which
is making room for the actors.
We wanted to put Annie's
house on the stage.
We didn't want to have
an idea about a house,
or some comment from
outside, or an opinion.
We wanted to give her the
place where she lived,
that we could reveal more story
that way, that we could find--
and that we wanted-- and this
was a word we used endlessly--
we wanted claustrophobia.
We wanted a kind of super
claustrophobic realism.
And so anytime you
break the plane,
you allow the
audience to breathe.
And that's why we don't
have an intermission.
It's why there's no blackouts.
There aren't meant
to be rest moments.
And so the idea was let's
put her whole house on stage.
And then once we go--
when the house moves,
we want to follow-- we
want to be in real time.
It is, again, the thing
Michael was saying about,
like we go back all the time.
And when the house
is in motion, we
want it to be really
in motion, happening
in front of your eyes.
And so the idea was to
just try and jam it all.
I remember David
calling me one day
and saying-- or me calling him
and saying, how's it going?
He said, I'm almost
being a good set
designer, because I've almost
got it all on the turntable.
And before that,
we would have bits
like, oh, we can't get the
stairs on the turntable.
And we just kept compressing it.
And every time we
compressed it, it
got more claustrophobic
and more real.
And we just kept pushing
it further and further
in that direction.
And then you and
David would talk about
what was in the house,
so that everything
has texture and detail and
is informed by the story,
not just comment from outside.
And also, that I
was always taken
by the idea of a cabin in the
woods and a kind of "Hansel
and Gretel" kind
of feeling of like,
that I thought it was important
to have the desolation,
to really feel that
this was happening
in the middle of nowhere.
So that was how we did it.
And we just kept
going with that idea
instead of pushing it
further and further.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
So is it interesting?
Laurie, have you ever
worked with a set like this?
You basically don't get
any time to breathe.
You and Bruce are on stage
pretty much the whole time.
As he said, it's real time,
including the passage of time.
LAURIE METCALF: We do have
some moments of tag team, where
Bruce is on stage
alone and figuring out
how he's going to get out of
the room with whatever key
he can manufacture, and stuff.
But when he's doing
that, I'm backstage
getting ready for
something else.
We don't really leave it.
We do get literally
stuck on that thing.
ALAN SEALES: Is
there a big crew back
there that's all of
a sudden just coming
to dump props and everything,
and take the snow off the side?
LAURIE METCALF: Our tech
week was hellish, because--
WILL FREARS: It was awesome.
LAURIE METCALF: --as you're
timing the light cues
with the music and the
revolve, then Bruce
is timing how fast he's
going in a wheelchair,
and the lights are
shift, and the music--
it's all shifting as he
passes through the doorway.
And then you reveal the hallway.
And your audience is seeing
it for the first time.
But it was so
intricate, and we just
had to time it over and
over and over again.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: You were
very patient with us--
MARK KAUFMAN: --as we
tortured you with music.
ALAN SEALES: Has the turntable--
LAURIE METCALF: 25 scenes,
and each one has a--
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: Oh, don't ask.
Don't ask that question.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: No, and
don't ask, That's a curse.
LAURIE METCALF: What did he say?
Oh, "Has it."
ALAN SEALES: Has the turntable--
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: No.
WILL FREARS: No.
ALAN SEALES: Good
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN:
No, don't say ever.
Please don't say it.
MARK KAUFMAN: Never broken.
ALAN SEALES: What would happen--
LAURIE METCALF: But there
was a million props also.
The handling of
all that had to get
swept up into this tech week.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: We
had a bad few days,
where in spring, there
was some snow on the roof.
ALAN SEALES: People just
forgot to take it off?
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: No,
no one knew how to.
There was no moment in
which it could be taken off.
Somehow they
heroically take it off.
ALAN SEALES: It's
all very subtle.
I love it.
Because you see the flowers
get put on the porch, and then
all of a sudden, oh yeah,
the snow is melting.
Yeah, it all just worked.
LAURIE METCALF:
And I think Bruce
and I are wearing, individually,
like seven layers of things.
It doesn't seem like there would
be a lot of wardrobe changes,
but there are.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, so you
just layer everything then?
LAURIE METCALF: Yeah, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: I guess Bruce--
LAURIE METCALF: And quick ones
happening backstage, a lot
of quick stuff back there.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
So the rehearsals you
were talking about,
how long were they?
You said they were
six to seven weeks?
WILL FREARS: No.
ALAN SEALES: Longer?
Pfft.
Along three weeks?
LAURIE METCALF: Three.
WILL FREARS: Three
weeks in the room.
So three weeks with--
and Bruce as well.
And then a week in
the theater in tech.
And then four weeks of
previews, so we would rehearse
in the afternoon, and then these
guys would have to go on and do
it in the evening.
And then they'd get
handed endlessly, like,
oh, we want to
change everything.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
I was going to ask
if the script kept changing
up until opening night.
WILL FREARS: Oh, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Even afterwards?
WILL FREARS: Not
opening, but close.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Yeah.
Question over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Chris.
Thanks to everybody for coming.
This is very cool.
I'm curious, with "Misery" being
such an iconic film, and a book
before that, and it coming to
the stage for the first time,
how do you balance using what
came before as inspiration,
but not letting it
make whatever you do
and create-- not
reducing the freshness?
Do you use it for inspiration?
Or do you just clean slate,
kind of power through?
LAURIE METCALF: Well,
I was clever enough
to stay away from the movie,
because I knew if I watched-- I
saw the movie when it came out.
But if I looked at
that again, which
I'm going to as
soon as we close--
I want to see it
again-- but I knew
that Kathy's wonderful
performance would stick
in my head in a really bad way.
But I did go back to the
book, which I had also
read when it came out.
And to revisit that
was really helpful.
It's a lot about Paul
Sheldon's interior life
and the torture that he's
having to take from this woman.
The book is also
very, very theatrical.
There's a lot of
really-- even more
gruesome things happen
in the book that
were chosen to be in the movie.
And then ours is
a hybrid of both.
Because we have things
that are from the book,
that weren't in the
movie, and vice versa.
So there were so
many options, I felt,
going into "Misery"
the play, that it
was daunting in that way.
But I like that it's a blend.
WILL FREARS: One of the things
that we realized when we did it
in Pennsylvania was that he's
stuck on stage the whole time.
He's stuck in this room,
and so you have to--
and this was what's
wonderful about the movie.
And because I am a
coward, I'd never
watched the movie because the
trailer scared me too much.
So I didn't watch it until
I sat in the NYU hospital
room with my
two-day-old on my chest.
But the movie is
brilliant in what it takes
from-- the book is spectacular.
And it's all in
Paul's voice, and it's
all Paul's point of view.
And what Bill Goldman
does in the movie that's
so brilliant, as a human,
he finds this new way
of looking at Annie, and
going out into Annie's world.
And it's wonderful.
But then when you
went back to the play,
you were like, we
don't have a camera.
This can only happen between
the two of them in this room.
And so everything sort
of got-- the stuff
we took from the book, the
stuff we got from the movie,
it all had to be
recompressed into
like, how does this happen
between the two of them?
How can this happen
in the space that
exists in their conversation
or in what they're not saying?
And I think that was the big--
that everything from both
the mediums had to be
channeled back into like,
can this take place
between the two of them
in the space that exists
between the two of them?
And I think that was our
main-- I went back to the movie
at the end.
Once it was all
worked out in my head,
and I would be sort
of stuck in places.
And then I felt like I
had a secure enough grip
of the story I was telling,
that then I would go back and be
like, how did they do it?
Because I might just steal that.
So I would use it.
Once I knew what I
was doing, I felt
liberated to steal from very,
very clever people in a way
that, earlier on, I would
have felt, as Laurie says,
like I would have just ended up
trying to mimic a lot of stuff
from the movie, rather
than at the end,
being able to go
back and be like,
oh, oh, I'll have a bit of that.
That's clever.
And so that was it, but
I haven't seen the movie.
So I can't remember the last
time I watched the whole movie.
I would watch and be like
how do they do that bit?
And I would go back and watch
that over and over again.
LEON ADDISON BROWN:
I saw the movie
when it came out many years ago.
And reading the book,
I was a little shocked
that Buster is actually
a composite, I think,
of different police
officers that show up.
And so I didn't have to-- I was
hoping that I could get stuff
from the book for him.
But I had to go find my own
cop book which was amazing.
Mr. Goldman must have
sat down and talked
to detectives, or something.
Because some of the
answers that she gives
are all these cues and
clues in it about, hmm,
there's something here.
There's something
here in every scene.
And I was like, thank you.
MARK KAUFMAN: Can I--
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, go ahead.
MARK KAUFMAN: --I just want
to add one thing, though.
One of the things I think
we've done very successfully
is when we sought out to
do this in the first place,
we have the book.
You have the movie.
And we wanted to create
something that was its own.
So yes, it pulls
from the other ones.
But it has things that are
also unique to the play that
aren't in either the
book or the movie.
So we set out to not create
a souvenir of either,
but a companion piece,
the same way the movie
is a companion
piece of the book.
And I think that's what
we've done successfully.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: And one
more thing, which is there's
one iconic moment in the
movie that is not in the book,
or it's very different in
the book, which is probably
the most famous iconic moment
in the movie-- no spoilers.
But we had to get that right.
WILL FREARS: Yes.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: We knew.
And we didn't quite get
it right in Pennsylvania,
and the audience
didn't quite forgive us
for not getting it right.
And no, and it was the big
thing we had to get right.
And it was pretty exciting when
the actors, and the designers,
and the director, and
all the stage hands,
when everyone
finally came together
to make that moment work was
really probably when we knew.
The audience reaction suddenly
was like, oh, we gave you
what you were waiting for.
And that's also a
very wonderful thing
to be able to do
for an audience.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Were you influenced at all
by the music in the movie?
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: I quickly
started watching it.
And Marc Shaiman wrote
a really good score.
It's Marc Shaiman, right?
MARK KAUFMAN: Marc Shaiman,
the "Hairspray" composer.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: Marc
Shaiman, who did "Hairspray,
wrote a really good score.
It's actually
strangely unhelpful
because movies are so
different from plays.
So it was nice to
start watching it
and go, oh, I couldn't use that.
None of this would work.
ALAN SEALES: [CHUCKLES]
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN:
Let's start over.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Yeah.
Question over here?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Mark, you mentioned that
"Misery" spoke to you
because of the theatricalism
you felt inherent in the piece.
I was wondering, in general,
when Warner Brothers
is choosing shows to adapt for
the theater, what you look for.
And also, more to
the point, if there
is going to be a
"Goonies-- The Musical"?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK KAUFMAN: Wow.
ALAN SEALES: Good question.
MARK KAUFMAN: Well, again,
there are different ways
to do theater.
There's the musical.
There's the play.
There are reviews.
There are now immersive theater,
like there are pieces where
you follow the actors around.
So as far as what
we look for, it's
just something that
feels like it naturally
adapts to the stage.
It has to have a theatricality.
It has to feel like
you could transform it
into something else.
It feels like, to me, though,
when we're putting theater
together, it's the next step.
It can't just be, oh,
let's take the movie
and just do it on stage.
Like I said before
about "Misery,"
it can't be the
souvenir of the piece.
it has to be a companion piece.
And what can you add to the
piece by putting it on stage?
I think with "Elf," we
were very successful.
And "Hairspray" was
incredibly successful
because the John Waters movie
and the musical on Broadway
were two complete
different things,
as I feel the Adam Shankman
movie was another step forward.
And so I guess my
long answer to that
is that we look for something
that feels like it organically
feels like it belongs on stage,
where there is relationship,
some emotional arc, some sort
of reason to have it sing.
We're doing "Dave."
We're doing "Seventeen Again."
These pieces feel like
they belong on stage.
And I guess time will tell
whether we're right or not.
But we're trying.
ALAN SEALES: You mentioned
the audience a second ago.
The audience, they finally were
like, yes, you gave it to us.
This is what we want.
Is the overall audience
reaction this time--
I guess, first off,
first question, how
is it different here in New
York versus at Bucks County?
WILL FREARS: I think
we're different now.
I think part of it is
that in Bucks County,
we were testing it out.
And I think, I look
back, we were much more--
we worked in a way that I I'm
glad we've moved away from.
We did much more like we're
going to be scary now.
Like the thunder was
endlessly the loudest thunder
you'd ever heard.
And the lightning was
like really "lightningy."
And I think that--
ALAN SEALES: Lightningy.
WILL FREARS: Lightningy.
And I think that what we
did was we found a way,
and so in a way, we didn't
yet trust what we had.
I mean, we were
right not to, which
is that we didn't trust it,
so we handed over everything
to see what worked.
And I think that what we
came out of Pennsylvania
with was a much clearer sense
of the story we were telling.
I mean, it was the most-- I'd
like to do it with anything
I direct, which is do it once.
Figure out where you've
gotten off track,
and then go back and
do it again better.
To have had the opportunity to
learn from it was a real treat,
so thank you, Mark.
And I think we went back and
went like, oh, now we know
the story we're going to tell.
Now we can be more interesting.
We can be bolder.
We can be stranger because we
know what it is we're doing.
And we trust it more, so
we don't have to just make
the thunder really loud.
I mean, we do in
places still, but it's
less-- we stopped tap
dancing quite so fast.
And I think that's what we
came into rehearsal with.
And then I think Laurie and
Bruce, once they showed up,
brought such extra-- I think
that the actors in Pennsylvania
were very much that doing
what we needed them to do
to see what the play worked.
And Laurie and Bruce
bring such originality,
and eccentricity,
and strangeness to it
that it's become a kind
of-- the one in Pennsylvania
was really like,
here's the movie.
We're kind of figuring it out.
And here I think
we have a thing.
We've pulled the script apart.
Laurie and Bruce give
these sort of very strange,
very interesting, very
human performances.
The design leads in
more interesting places.
So it has a confidence
now, I think,
that it didn't have
in Bucks County.
In Bucks County, it
really was sort of--
ALAN SEALES: Experimentation.
WILL FREARS: Yeah, or
not experimentive enough,
where they're like, hey,
hey, do you like it?
Do you like it?
MARK KAUFMAN: The
set evolved also.
ALAN SEALES: I was
going to ask about that.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: A lot.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Was it
the original house
with the turntable there too?
MARK KAUFMAN: No.
WILL FREARS: The room
was quite similar.
The door was in the same place,
but I think that was about it.
No, no, you spend your
life trying to figure out
where the door goes.
Once you figure out
where the door goes,
pretty much everything
else makes sense.
But the door-- no,
how to you move?
She comes in.
He's in bed.
Nobody's moving, so you've got
to figure out the relationship
between bed and door.
It's like 80% percent
of the blocking.
Desperate to get
away from the door.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Yeah, question over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question.
I guess when you first got
together in the room and said,
this is how we are going to
scare audiences and really
bring them in, how do you
think being in a theater
and seeing this
performance live is
different from being scared--
somebody sitting in a movie
theater and being brought into
a film versus being on stage
and seeing it?
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN:
Well, it's actually
happening in front of you.
I mean, which I know
is the obvious answer,
but it's also true.
These are real people.
I mean, that's my
experience watching this.
These are real people.
WILL FREARS: And real bodies.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: Yeah,
real people and real bodies.
And a few times, wait,
that can't be a real body.
But that experience
which is that this
is happening in front of you,
and they are actually doing it.
I mean there's a fight
at the end, where
Bruce and Laurie go at
each other in a rather
frightening way.
And a fight on stage is a
completely different thing
than a fight in a movie.
There's a little
bit of distance.
As exciting as the movie is,
it's a different and, I think,
a more distanced experience.
WILL FREARS: And I think that
the pleasure of being scared
in a movie so much
is the edit, that you
cut, you change
the angle, or you
play a thing that wasn't there.
And I think what we're going
for is that it builds up
to this incredibly kind of
climactic violent moment,
and to train the audience
to believe everything.
And what you do is
you keep not cutting.
You keep not going to black.
You keep not giving
a kind of [GASP]
so that it all-- there's a
sort of cumulative effect
of a different--
almost like you haven't
been allowed to stop looking.
Laurie is there the whole
time and you're going
to have to keep looking at her.
We're not cutting away.
We're not giving you anything
outside of this room.
I mean, the movie cuts
its passage of time.
It cuts to the mountains
and you watch the snow melt.
But you cut to the mountains,
and you breathe for a second.
We don't have any mountains.
We've only got--
LAURIE METCALF: We also don't
have the benefit of close-ups.
WILL FREARS: Yes.
LAURIE METCALF: So
that's a big one.
You can get a lot of mileage
out of a really good close-up,
and we can't do that.
WILL FREARS: No.
ALAN SEALES: There's a lot of
realistic blood as well, which
speaking as an audience
member not involved
in the production--
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: We
have a blood room.
ALAN SEALES: Do you, really?
WILL FREARS: Don't go in there.
ALAN SEALES: Buster just
goes in and coats himself.
Yeah, that was the difference
for me versus in a movie,
I guess.
Like I'm looking
at it, and I know
it's not real anyway,
because it's a movie.
But of course, in theater,
I know it's not real.
People aren't getting hurt every
night, over and over again--
most of the time.
But for me, like you said,
seeing real people involved
with this, and seeing
all of a sudden,
Buster's little climactic scene,
and the noise, and the boom,
it's-- all right.
I don't-- sorry.
WILL FREARS: No, I
just wanted to ask
you, Laurie, as the
person who is scary,
how much do you-- like I
have this idea about what
we're doing to scare people.
But you are the agent
of scariness on stage.
How much do you think
about that as you--
LAURIE METCALF: I don't
think about it at all.
Am I scary in it?
WILL FREARS: Terrifying, yes.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, yeah, yeah,
by the end of it, yeah.
WILL FREARS: Oh, and
like really scary.
LAURIE METCALF: Well,
hopefully, the reason for that
is that she's just
unpredictable, right?
ALAN SEALES: Right.
LAURIE METCALF: So you
don't know what-- first,
you start to get a hint of
what she might be capable of.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
LAURIE METCALF: So I
guess it's the-- yeah,
it's the unpredictability.
So I don't have to try
and actually scare people.
That's not where that's
coming from, right?
The fear is coming from.
Because it can't be.
Nobody can-- you look
this big on the stage.
No, that can't be scary.
WILL FREARS: I mean, it is.
LAURIE METCALF: But I
guess it's just her.
Sometimes the rage that's in
her, I guess, might be scary.
My kids don't think so,
but audiences might.
ALAN SEALES: We totally did.
And for me, like you said,
it's the unpredictability,
especially when it comes
to causing physical harm.
That's what pushed
me over the edge
is that, OK, she's
a little nuts.
She says some weird things.
And then all of a sudden,
like about halfway through.
it escalates very, very quickly.
And for me, watching it,
the character of Annie,
it was like just
another day in the park.
Like, oh, well, this is
what's going to happen,
and boom, there it happened.
And while the rest of us--
the audience-- is cringing.
And there are people all
around me in the audience
talking as if it's
a horror movie.
They're like, oh, my god.
Is she going to go inside?
What's going to happen?
It's going to hit her like that?
LAURIE METCALF: Really?
ALAN SEALES: Oh, yeah, there's
people whispering behind me,
like watch this.
What's going on?
And I realized that
people are literally
watching it like they're
watching a horror film.
MARK KAUFMAN: The
sound of 1,200 people
in the Longacre screaming--
WILL FREARS: The Broadhurst.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN:
--is like the coolest.
The Broadhurst--
don't mention that.
(LOUDLY) Broadhurst!
Screaming is like the awesomest
sound I've ever heard.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
it was incredible.
LAURIE METCALF: And laughing.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN: And laughing.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, there
were the funny parts
in there too, which was a
wonderful juxtaposition.
Man, your character, you just--
LAURIE METCALF: That's why
we call it a "thrilomedy."
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: It's like "The
Martian" being a comedy.
LAURIE METCALF: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
question over here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was actually going to
ask about what you just
touched upon.
But when I watched the
movie, I didn't find it
very funny or pleasant at all.
It was a very unsettling movie.
And then when I saw
it in the theater,
I saw it during previews,
so it might have changed.
But the scene everyone keeps
avoiding talking about--
[LAUGHTER]
LEON ADDISON BROWN:
The one where
Buster falls from the roof?
Or the one where--
ALAN SEALES: The bungee jumping.
AUDIENCE: --finally figures out.
And then, you know.
When I saw that, there were
a lot of shocked screams
but then this wave of laughter.
And I just thought that was
like a really-- I did not expect
the play to be like that.
But do you think that's
a necessary property
of doing horror in a theater?
Or is that something
you were going for?
Or a combination of both?
MARK KAUFMAN: I think we were
all surprised about-- I mean,
from when we started previews,
the audience's response
was terrific.
And I think what we were--
I, at least, personally,
what I was most
surprised about was
about how much
humor was in there,
and how people got
on for the ride.
And I wasn't sure whether it was
because they knew the character
from the book, or whether
they-- Laurie's performance is
extraordinary.
So whether they love her,
or hate her, or whatever,
they follow her.
And they feel sympathy for her.
And she really elicits
this amazing reaction
from the audience.
And I think some of it is
release, and some of it
is just because
they feel for her.
But it's genuine laughter,
which is pretty extraordinary.
MICHAEL FRIEDMAN:
I think sometimes,
though, in the theater, when
there's a moment of horror,
the audience has the
reaction and then realizes
they've all had the reaction.
And that part of the
humor that comes out of it
is what you said, the
release, which is,
we all just screamed together.
That was really scary.
And then they kind of
laugh, and it's almost
an automatic nervous response.
It's fun to watch the
audience in those moments
and try to figure
out the psychology.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, yeah.
It was after moments like
that that, and traditionally
through theater, you don't
talk through it, and whatnot.
But then as every moment
just stairstepped,
and the tension kept
building, people
were just having
whole conversations.
This one guy was sitting
behind me completely about
to just lose his mind
because he didn't know
what you were going to do next.
And it was exciting for me to
experience all these people
around me getting as
nervous and as excited
as I know that you
guys intend them to be.
So job accomplished,
job well done.
So thank you very much.
If there are no more
questions, we'll wrap up.
We're out of time here.
Playing at the Broadhurst
Theatre, 235 West 44th,
between 7th and 8th Avenue.
Miserybroadway.com.
Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram, /miserybroadway.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
MARK KAUFMAN: And
get your tickets now
because we only have
five more weeks.
ALAN SEALES: Five more
weeks, a limited run.
Yeah, get tickets now.
Cool.
Thank you.
WILL FREARS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]